i mean like the reason i really like
these this dozen was cause like the
first two chapters
um like when it started getting a bit
ntre i'm just like
uh you're kind of losing me here the
first time
yeah i think i wasn't the first time it
was because to me the first half was so
[ __ ] well done that i'm just like
okay i'm always going to remember this
was very good yeah i mean the r was good
but to me to me it was the story art was
good and the way that they broke down
the law
was really good because it's so [ __ ]
rare for me to find
like hentai and the jin shi they
actually give a [ __ ] about the story
yeah right
because like most like when when you
think of like for example most brother
sister hentai
it's just it's the most like simple [ __ ]
it's like
sister comes in wakes up brother oh no
you're hard i guess i'll suck you off
now and i'm just like
like that's dodging over yeah that's
that's exactly i'm just like that's
literally
everything like who gives a [ __ ] about
that i'm like it's like cool okay no i
got a perfect thing i need spice with my
hentai
okay surprise surprise surprise surprise
incest is not spiced fun
incest has never been spicy
it's illegal i mean that's i mean that's
why steps
that's why it's always [ __ ] step
siblings in hentai right they they love
they never go the full [ __ ] they never
do the full monty right
mother you'd be surprised that's not the
[ __ ] i watched
joey's like i can name it i tell you
what i can name like 10 off the top of
my head i'll tell you
the reason every hentai does it is
because it's like that disclaimer
that goes on like the beginning of every
youtube video was like this youtube
video is
fair use copyright this video is
protected under fair use
these simple things are not your honor
your honor these siblings are simply
steps
it is not illegal they are not blood
related they are just drawings
i am just playing devil's advocate
because you know it's very easy to make
someone who says i like incest look bad
so it's very fun
i mean i don't know why it's so
surprising when it's when you're talking
about gans i love domestic girlfriend
giggart you know
yeah because to me like i said breaking
taboo that is my taste
unfortunately it's it's so [ __ ] hard
because 99
of hentai when it comes to like breaking
taboo are just like the most depraved
ntr [ __ ] you can find on like god's [ __ ]
greener
i don't know i don't know there's so
much of it so many people are into it
man
you know i go you know you go on like
the hentai releases and yeah nowadays
it's like 60 to 70 percent of it it's
just ntr
garbage yeah it's like i can't not to
this
like like this majority of japan is not
right apparently all i want to [ __ ]
see
is two people who know they shouldn't be
together but just you know
for like one [ __ ] little rule break
having like a cheeky nando's you know
have a
have a cheeky little [ __ ] here and
there you know [ __ ]
you know have one or two hot nights and
then just doesn't need to know
and then just call it a day
unfortunately hentai takes us
as let's rip someone's life into pieces
while we do this that's what i was in
front of with this one they were like
i'm just gonna i'm gonna tell them
that that part really [ __ ] me up no no
why would you do that
the part the part that i that made the
least sense to me was just like you know
like here and i was just like i've left
now i fixed their marriage i'm just like
in what way have you fixed that [ __ ]
marriage
your matchmaker i fix their marriage by
literally getting my brother to [ __ ] me
all over his house
every part of his house we've had like a
threesome where we're just not going to
be able to talk about for years i'm not
getting busy
i'm not going to be able to look at my
wife in the eyes like years to come
jesus imagine if we
imagine if we have kids like what the
[ __ ] i love how after that like a
[ __ ]
intense threesome scene and like curing
our leaves there's just like this
monologue of kyousuke being like
monami and i talked it out we're mending
our wounds
oh it's that easy isn't it
i know i kind of just [ __ ] my sister
and [ __ ] you at the same time
um but i i think we can i think i think
we can work through this right happy
wife happy life
she's like yeah i'm glad this is like
never happened before right yeah
this is just a phase right it's just the
phase yeah
it just happened one time right yeah
yeah
the dna test results have come in
because like cause like
when when you see cheating in hentai
normally it's like you're like the
person is cheating against this [ __ ]
faceless dude that you you don't see
right it's like it's like
i'm not a fan of it the character having
an active part in the story yeah you
know
i mean that's that's the difference
between cheating and ntr you know yeah
yeah like even [ __ ] kirino's husband
comes back at this even though he's like
a faceless [ __ ] guy and just like
[ __ ] like where did that come from
yeah i love that and he was just like i
love the ending scene too because he
gets absolutely
the [ __ ] kicked out of him and kiosk is
just like
worth it he's like right i'm still
protecting kieran i'm just like what
what is going on here
that would go how did that would go huh
but yeah the reason the reason this is
one of my favorite series
like parody doujins of all time is
because of the first two chapters the
first two chapters
10 out of 10. that is that is my exact
taste i'm not gonna lie
one thing that really did put me off i
didn't make a note of this i'm like okay
why is he
why is she being like he get me pregnant
but then be like uh no no
that was really [ __ ] weird can we can
we admit that that's kind of weird
okay shooting with your step brother is
really pushing it
what i could accept to be like oh he he
it's hard yeah but then being like she's
like
make me pregnant literally the first
time she meets and i'm like what are
some things
what am i supposed to think here to be
like dead that's hard dude impregnate
your sister
that'll show him that'll show everyone i
think this is i i
you saying this now i think this just
shows that i've just been so sensitive
[Applause]
there's always that one panel in every
hand side which is like make me pregnant
or i'm going to become pregnant i am
trying to be supportive of my friends
tasters
and i'm reading this you know and i want
to be like good for god yeah
yeah but then like it's literally again
the amount of times i do i'm going to
reference the [ __ ] headset meme where
he rips it off
i'm trying to get into this and she's
like make me pregnant i'm like [ __ ]
[ __ ] why why what do you mean
i think i think it's just because there
sometimes your tastes are like
like my taste is like so specific that
it's it's
it's kind of like i'm willing to look
over some of like the weirdest [ __ ]
or the weirder aspects of some hentai if
there's like this aspect that it's done
like ridiculously ridiculously well
you know you sound like someone who's
like desperately digging for
good heads after you've had it all
you're like i've seen something
i need to feel something i'll forgive
you if i feel about the weird [ __ ]
[ __ ]
just for a crumb of good blow job if it
scratches
if it scratches that one tiny itch
that's that's all i need that's all i
need this is [ __ ] weird
i did give this one a three out of ten
three three
honestly that was those very few moments
where i was like this is hot
and there's so many moments so i'm like
[ __ ] out
[ __ ] like i i don't even know and i
wanted a smoke breakout
this is this is a dozen read and you're
like i need a [ __ ] smoke
i don't even smoke and i was like [ __ ] i
need a cigarette just like [ __ ] look
out my window and be like [ __ ]
the thousands but i feel like that's to
me that that's what makes a great dosing
like if if if it can [ __ ] affect you
in some way
then it's it that means at least changes
your life no that means that
at least it's doing something right
right it's making you feel something
right
i'm just waiting for something to happen
it doesn't matter what disgust anything
i'll make it work
my dick is numb by my heart aches
three out of ten where'd you go get this
one joey
i don't know i weirdly enjoyed this one
um yes
[ __ ] yes yeah oh my god this is why you
know we nee
we need a me on this podcast to balance
out the [ __ ] degeneres
that we have over here this is how i
know joey's a brother i really enjoy
this one i'll give this like a
that's probably seven or an eight yeah
god damn it yeah story's spicy man
again it's a it's a spicy story this is
not
literally the word spice went out the
window when he told a [ __ ] mom that
was when i was like this is not spicy
that's like exact that's like by the
that's like the last [ __ ] panel
should have already nutted by then you
don't give a [ __ ] about it i don't
i don't want it i don't i don't want to
get post not clarity and then also find
out afterwards he told the mom yeah
that's like the biggest whiplash of
posting on clarity you'd be like you're
like
oh god oh jesus that's not spice that's
like a carolina reaper to the eye
oh god god would you just run out ten
then for you personally
nine oh my god the the good parts were
so good that i'm just like i
it's to me it's the it's the most
like the most unique do like parody
dojin i've read so far in terms of
building on a premise and being able to
like
take this premise in an anime and just
make a hot situation just the dildo burn
did it for me like that
yeah yeah that was [ __ ] hilarious i
respectfully disagree